do you have any idea what the hell is
going on in Texas right now I've told
you a little bit about these turn Texas
blue movements the idea that if you
really focus on the bluer or more purple
areas of Texas potentially you could
turn Texas from a reliable red state
into a swing state within a couple of
election cycles we have a new poll from
the admittedly democratic polling firm
PPP which has Donald Trump only six
points ahead of Hillary Clinton in Texas
5244 an average of recent Texas polls
which I will show you now has Donald
Trump ahead by eight point four points
you'll notice the PPP poll there has it
Trump plus six whereas the KTVT poll
says Trump plus 11 and the Texas Tribune
poll has it at Trump plus eight an
average lead for Donald Trump in Texas
of 8.4 but the most recent poll saying
Trump plus six this is stunning it is
shocking it is reflective of how insane
this year's election is but I hope
you're sitting down for this this is the
truly crazy thing going on in Texas
right now you know there's the
secessionist movement in Texas of some
people in Texas mostly right-wingers who
want to separate and become the country
of texas no longer part of the United
States the PPP poll also polled its
respondents on the topic of secession
and the ideological split is in saying
let's break this down piece by piece
check out this quote from the poll and
we'll walk through it overall twenty-six
percent of texas voters would support
leaving the United States while
fifty-nine percent of texas voters want
to stay fifteen percent aren't sure love
to talk to that fifteen percent who says
I might want my state to be part of the
US but I might not i'm just not sure
right now among trump voters this is the
key line among trump voters support for
secession goes up to thirty seven
percent with only forty-nine percent
opposed to exiting this is amazing
clinton leads Trump 54 241
among those who want Texas to remain
part of the u.s. so if you divide Texas
into people who say yeah I'm interested
in my state being part of the US and
those who say I am interested in my
state leaving Hillary is killing Trump
in Texas among voters who want to remain
as part of the United States um that
makes perfect sense to me doesn't it I
mean the craziest thing would be that if
she were leading with the secessionists
right you will of course but the idea
that even intact you would think okay
listen you've got the secessionist
movement in Texas but it's really not
that big and it's not completely
concentrated on the right or whatever so
Texas is just generally read so you
wouldn't expect Hillary to have a
13-point lead among the secession among
the non secessionists in Texas that is
truly incredible uh also the fact that
she does seem to have some support from
secessionists yeah I did it's just uh
Texas is becoming an increasingly
confusing place yeah no doubt about that
Trump's lead in Texas is also based on
holding the senior vote Trump is leading
the senior citizen vote 63 233 with
voters under 65 right so if Texas had
only people under 65 vote Hillary
Clinton is ahead there when you look at
up voters under age 45 Hillary Clinton
is up by 25 percentage points in Texas
older voters are overwhelmingly
responsible for the Republican advantage
in Texas so when you look Louis at the
idea of turning Texas blue and you say
hey hold on a second increased
percentage of the population identifies
as hispanic or latino they tend to vote
for democrats uh you have the older
voters aging out they are the ones
disproportionately voting for
republicans it is not crazy to think
about texas becoming a swing state in
the near future now just to show you how
huge this would be I ran an electoral
map to show you where I switched Texas
to blue okay Texas if Texas were to go
blue I then gave Donald Trump and I'm
not saying Texas will go blue this year
but imagine a future where it does
if Texas goes blue you can give Florida
to Donald Trump you can give Ohio to
Donald Trump you can give Georgia which
is in play now to Donald Trump you can
give I 0 which is considered a tie right
now to Donald Trump you give Trump New
Hampshire which is the lone New England
state that he might actually be able to
win give Trump Nevada give them Utah
give'em Arizona give them everything
right give him everything but if you
keep Texas blue Hillary Clinton still
wins without any of those other states
she doesn't need a single one of those
hugely important states so I get Louis
what it would mean for national
electoral politics if you throw Texas
into the swing state category it will
happen right it mean imagine in 10 years
20 years it's it's got to happen and
your mic was absolutely on during that
right it was absolutely good terrific
but we really haven't been having issues
with that lately which I'm thrilled
about it some I've been rated it's my
fault when things go wrong sigh like
there's a technical issue and
something's broken it's my fault when
that happens and I've been performing
well on the ball no doubt about it I've
talked about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com slash david